like i mentioned earlier there was 47
000 wounded
during the battle the bulge so instead
of
the ships being able to take people home
on furlough you ended up on these ships
getting people transported where back to
england yeah
to portsmouth england
of course portsmouth england
is where we'd stop and unload those
ships again
and then go back and get another load
see
and and here i'm supposed to be headed
across the atlantic
and
but
think of this
when i do get home
when i do get home and spend my 45 days
at home
i go up to fort snelling
and a captain calls calls me in he says
sergeant
10 minutes 10 minutes ago i got a call
from the pentagon
and they told me that
i
they they let me
i could stay home or go back to germany
my god after three years over there
there's no way i'm going back to germany
so all all the relics that i had under
colonel hill's
bed
they were given up
don't know what happened and i don't
miss some one of them
[Laughter]
so that that's uh
as you as you get home
i can't even imagine
going from that many months of direct
combat
and just
getting on a ship getting back to
america what was it like when you got
home especially before you found out
that you were going to get to stay home
oh wait
my mother was
dying from a heart disease called
leakage of the heart it was a valve
in there
and
i i never thought i'd see her
anymore
but she was still living
and she lived for
five years after that
she
saw her grandchildren two of her
grandchildren at that time and
i i say there is a god
but
two weeks after my mother passed away
not dr hoffnagel in washington d.c
invented that valve
that would have cured her
but
you can't turn back time
if
it's like crying over spilt milk say
you can't pick it up
it's done